she actually works for garth brooks so
she's used to being on the other side of
the camera
but i asked her if she would be in this
and she decided that she would
i know it sounds kind of crazy but
that's the only way i can say it
being beside
love is love and our love looks like
just everyone else's
except we're just two girls who fell in
love it's incredible to see other people
seeing themselves within our story and
finally feeling like
they can be represented by another lgbtq
[Music]
member
we've been talking a lot about the
inclusivity um or lack thereof in
country music historically
and where we're at now and how things
are changing is it something that you
see
a lot more that you notice i definitely
see our genre
realizing that we need to step up you
know we're
in control of of who gets played and who
gets seen
and it's amazing to see you know like my
friend mickey guyton who's one of the
best
artists that i've ever heard sing
getting the recognition that she
deserves
and tj osborne being able to come out
and do his thing
and i definitely see us moving forward
in a much quicker trajectory than i've
ever seen